Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Il y a environ moins de quatre ans,
j’ai reçu un coup de téléphone
qui m’a beaucoup troublé.
C’était un coup de téléphone
me demandant de participer à une Red Team
organisée par PSL -
Paris Sciences et Lettres,
c’est l’ensemble
des universités parisiennes -
pour les armées françaises.
J’étais un peu déconcerté parce
que je n’ai jamais été très militariste.
Je n'ai pas fait mon service.
Je n’ai jamais beaucoup
travaillé l’image militaire -
ni l’image de guerre d’ailleurs.
Et donc je ne savais pas trop
comment je devais prendre ça.
Il faut dire qu’on est
bien avant la guerre en Ukraine.
Je crois que depuis,
on a un peu changé de regard
sur le sujet des armées et tout ça.
Quand même,
on se sent un peu plus fragiles.
Beaucoup de mes amis me disaient :
« Mais qu’est-ce que tu vas faire là ?
À quoi ça va servir de t’aventurer
dans ce monde que tu connais si mal ? »
Ce qui m’a vraiment interpellé,
c’était d’abord que
les armées sont intéressées à travailler
avec des auteurs de science-fiction.
On le sait, les cinémas - le cinéma
américain, mais pas seulement -
ont donné à voir le monde du futur,
peut-être bien mieux
que certains spécialistes
militaires ou politiques.
Ils ont eu des capacités comme ça
à se dégager du réel
et à nous donner à voir
le monde de demain.
En cela, c’était vraiment formidable
de sentir ce désir des armées
de s’ouvrir à l’imaginaire
d’auteurs et d’autrices.
Parce que c’était ça, l’idée :
regarder le monde de demain,
un monde inquiétant.
On est en 2040, 2050, 2060,
donc c’est vraiment
de l’anticipation très très poussée.
On prend beaucoup de risques
en proposant ces récits.
En même temps, il faut
la crédibilité, bien sûr.
Il ne s’agit pas de de faire descendre
des petits hommes verts sur Terre,
ça n’aurait pas vraiment,
je pense, convaincu l’équipe.
On était dans une équation
fantastique - réel
pour produire du récit,
pour produire de bonnes histoires.
C’est par saison.
Il y en a eu une zéro, puis trois,
donc quatre saisons on va dire.
À chaque fois deux récits
qui doivent vraiment marquer,
qui doivent être assez imposants -
qui ont été publiés d’ailleurs.
Ce qui est intéressant,
c’est le processus, en fait.
Le processus, c’était d’abord cette
Red Team, deux auteurs, deux autrices,
un concepteur visuel, une graphiste,
une designer.
On avait une équipe qui devait
être très homogène, très organique,
pour produire ces images et ces récits.
Et ça a été une aventure, parce que...
le processus, c’est d’abord
d’être confronté à une Blue Team.
La Blue Team,
ce sont les experts militaires.
Eux, ils sont là pour nous cadrer
et nous dire le moment
où vraiment on déborde,
où on n’est pas dans le sujet,
où éventuellement ce qu’on fait
ne les intéresse pas.
Et il y avait aussi une Purple Team.
Ça, c’était quelque chose d’intéressant
puisqu’on avait accès
aux scientifiques de toute l’équipe PSL,
mais aussi aux scientifiques
du monde entier.
Ils pouvaient comme ça
nous aider à regarder ces scénarios,
à voir leur crédibilité, à voir
si on pouvait encore aller plus loin,
nous pousser encore à aller
dans d’autres dimensions.
Et il y avait une Black Team
qui est là un peu pour nous gérer,
pour nous accompagner,
pour nous aider à produire ces récits.
C’est dans ce cadre, dans
ce processus qu’on a travaillé.
On va bientôt terminer
la troisième saison.
C'était une fameuse aventure.
Il y a un dessin que j’ai fait comme ça,
qui était un peu mes inquiétudes.
C’est-à-dire le dessinateur
sous pression des militaires.
En fait, ça n'a pas du tout été le cas.
Et heureusement d’ailleurs,
parce que c’est un peu par provocation,
pour dire :
« Il faut qu’on reste des auteurs,
il faut qu’on reste
avec notre imaginaire. »
La chance qu’on avait,
c’était de pouvoir le développer.
Ce qu’il s’est passé, c’est que -
Il fallait que le dessin reste vivant,
il fallait qu’il soit
au cœur des scénarios.
Je ne voulais pas être un illustrateur
qui arrive tardivement,
qui regarde ça
et qui vient juste faire en sorte que
ça ressemble à quelque chose visuellement.
Voici un scénario intéressant.
C’est un scénario sur la montée des eaux
et comment il allait se créer
des zones de non-droit,
des zones entre la mer, l’eau et la terre,
avec des pirates, des nouveaux pirates,
avec peut-être des corsaires d’ailleurs,
avec tout un monde lié
à ces territoires envahis par l’eau.
Ce sont des dessins faits très rapidement,
en un quart d’heure, sans crayonner,
pour essayer de saisir
un peu l’esprit, la créativité,
qui se déploient au milieu
de ces auteurs et autrices.
Ça, c'est un dessin sur l'énergie.
On sait qu’aujourd’hui
plus personne ne pourra être totalement
isolé des problèmes énergétiques.
Les armées elles-mêmes devront
sans doute en tenir compte.
Elles devront sans doute envisager leur
intervention par rapport à l’énergie.
Tout leur attirail, je dirais,
consomme de plus en plus d’énergie.
Comment vont-ils gérer cette énergie ?
Est-ce qu’elle viendra du ciel,
des satellites, de drones ?
C’étaient des questions très
intéressantes, ça a été un sujet.
Ça, c'est un scénario qui n'a pas été
développé et que j'aimais bien.
C’était comment on peut travailler
sur l’émotion des soldats.
Comment, en connaissant
leurs réseaux sociaux,
on peut arriver à aller chercher
en la mémoire des choses très personnelles
et brusquement,
sur une situation de combat,
faire surgir cette mémoire
pour déstabiliser les soldats.
C’était amusant ; ça n’a pas été retenu,
Parce qu'en fait, dans ce genre de choses,
les dessins sont là pour produire.
Ils ne sont pas là évidemment
toujours pour arriver à bon terme.
C’est un peu un laboratoire, d’ailleurs,
un laboratoire d’idées et d’images.
Là, c’est sur ces espèces de murs
virtuels, de protections invisibles.
Comment est-ce qu’on parle
aujourd’hui de toute une dimension
qui n’est pas véritablement visible ?
Les dessins sont là pour exprimer parfois
des choses qui sont un peu abstraites.
À un moment donné,
ce qui était intéressant aussi,
c’était de montrer d’abord
toute une série d’images
qui sont des images
pour ouvrir un peu l’espace,
pour donner une dimension sur un sujet.
Le sujet en question, sur lequel
je vais essayer d’aller un peu plus loin,
c’est le sujet sur l’invisible.
C’est comment on pourrait
détourner le vivant,
comment on pourrait travailler sur
des aspects qui nous sont bien -
comment dire ? -
qui n’apparaissent pas, mais qui sont là
et qui constituent notre vie.
Comment on pourrait
nous déstabiliser fortement
en travaillant sur notre microbiote,
en travaillant sur le mycélium.
Comment une forêt
pourrait être brusquement
un lieu extrêmement inquiétant.
Ça encore, ce sont
des esquisses sur la façon
dont les soldats de demain
pourraient nous protéger
face à un ensemble de choses.
Ça part dans toutes les directions.
Ce qui était amusant, c’est que
je photographiais ces dessins,
puis, je les montrais
aux auteurs et autrices
pour arriver à essayer de voir
comment ils les intégraient,
comment ils réagissaient.
Comment une forêt, brusquement,
devient un lieu extrêmement inquiétant,
Le mycélium étant un révélateur,
un capteur de présence,
et fait que brusquement,
les soldats sont complètement en danger
puisqu’ils ne sont plus du tout
invisibles, mais ils sont repérés
avec cette transformation,
cette déformation du vivant.
Évidemment, ce sont des scénarios
qui ne sont pas rassurants.
Parfois même, on en avait peur.
Je me rappelle, la ministre des Armées
nous avait dit, pour lancer la Red Team,
elle avait dit : « Faites-nous peur. »
Je ne sais pas si on leur a fait peur,
mais c’est sûr qu’on s’est fait
aussi un peu peur
parce que le monde de demain
sera très étonnant, effrayant,
et aussi sans doute avec des beautés
qu'on n'imagine pas encore.
Évidemment, ici,
notre job, c’est quand même de construire
ce qu’il peut y avoir de pire.
En fait, c’est faire un peu
un crash test pour un pays,
c’est imaginer des situations
presque inimaginables.
Et c’est là le travail des auteurs
de science-fiction.
Comment aussi les nouvelles technologies
pourraient transformer
un habit militaire,
une protection militaire,
avec toutes les technologies,
les biotechnologies.
Et les dangers avec les bio-hackers.
Comment des gens pourraient bidouiller
de l’ADN sur des imprimantes
et faire des dégâts considérables.
C’est sûr que c’est un scénario
un peu vertigineux
qui me fait un peu peur.
Là, ce sont des dessins
qui vont plus loin,
qui essayent de montrer justement,
par exemple, comment le microbiote
est un élément qui pourrait
avoir des effets considérables
si on arrive à intervenir
à l’échelle d’une armée.
C’est ça qui est amusant avec un dessin,
c’est comment il peut donner à voir des
choses un peu bizarres, pour être franc.
Chaque dessin, à ce moment-là,
pouvait donner lieu à un dessin
beaucoup plus travaillé, plus poussé,
qui est le résultat
des scénarios vraiment développés.
Ici, ces fameuses forêts,
alors qu’elles sont si chatoyantes,
si passionnantes,
elles peuvent devenir un lieu totalement
inquiétant, totalement effrayant.
Ces basculements-là,
c’était au cœur de notre projet :
ce qu’on croit parfois paisible
devient un enfer.
Il y a des sujets comme ces protections,
Ces super-protections
qui seraient invisibles
mais qui pourraient protéger
des porte-avions.
Tout un scénario s’est développé,
ce qu’on a appelé les super-forteresses,
et qui auraient une capacité à déceler
les moindres interventions
dans l’air ou dans la mer.
On le voit, les scénarios étaient
extrêmement divers, extrêmement variés.
Là, sur l’énergie, le dessin
est un peu plus poussé.
Là c’est assez amusant parce que
les soldats sont des soldats,
mais c’est aussi comme des anges
parce qu’ils captent l’énergie.
Mais ils ont un aspect et protecteur,
et un peu inquiétant.
C’est un dessin pour ça
qui me semblait intéressant.
Une des dimensions
qui pourraient faire peur,
c’est ce monde où chacun
est dans sa bulle numérique,
dans un espace qui l’isole tellement
que s’il y a des interventions militaires,
ils seraient bien embarrassés
de communiquer avec le citoyen,
les citoyens étant à ce moment-là
totalement - comment dire ? -
prisonniers de leur espace personnel.
On voit bien
qu’on a élaboré plein de scénarios.
On a appris à un moment donné que ces
histoires, qui semblaient si fantastiques,
en réalité, elles avaient
vraiment aidé les militaires.
C'était une de nos grosses surprises.
Nous, on avait l’impression
d’être les fous du roi.
Eh bien non, ça avait servi
à quelque chose.
Ils nous ont dit les choses
auxquelles ils ont pensé
qui ont manifestement modifié
un certain nombre de leurs décisions.
En résumé, ce qui était formidable
dans cette aventure,
c’est d’abord d’apprendre,
d’apprendre à comprendre ce monde
qui est si complexe, si brouillé parfois,
et de voir toutes les choses
qui pourraient arriver.
Ce n’est pas très amusant
à imaginer le pire.
Mais en même temps,
c’est une lucidité nécessaire.
On a besoin de ça parce qu’on a
besoin de gens qui pensent au pire
pour que nous puissions aussi
imaginer le meilleur.
Et c’est en cela que je crois qu’il ne
faut pas perdre le désir de nos rêves,
le plaisir du futur,
mais il faut avoir la lucidité
aussi de regarder le pire.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)